word has spread that I'm in town and the
dining room is full all having the same
five core set menu cooked in the inn's
tiny kitchen practice at least our job
that's gnarly
that's ghastly what the watery business
was there that's probably that tomato
juice
unless it's condensation from the shrimp
condensation was it first yes it's a
sad-looking shrimp and everyone else
seems to be hating it too
how can you [ __ ] up with us hey Gordon
is it fresh salmon frozen frozen that
has to be the saddest looking plate of
salmon anywhere in North America tonight
[Music]
tastes great I mean thank you I just
wanted to take a long walk on a short
pier I want him to fall into a very deep
pit so he can't get out this is pathetic
conjunct of anything very good meaning
he can't cook an egg for me a sure thing
okay he can't possibly mess up a
soft-boiled egg can he what I'm just
like going is this really happening
he can't even born a [ __ ] egg [ __ ]
thing's still got feathers on it
[Music]
absolutely ready to boot Gordon Ramsay
out of my in IRA lately
are you having a laugh at your family's
expense no Victo ha big jacket and you
can't boil a [ __ ] egg Donna fried egg
you want french toast too how about some
pancakes what the [ __ ] are you doing you
don't caddy I do care they're a [ __ ]
joke those are what we refer to as
fighting words gutsy thing to do
especially in a kitchen full of sharp
knives it has never been a joke's on me
ever come play in my school I'm the
headmaster you're acting like an
absolute idiot no but you're in my house
that's right I'm disgusted in your
performance your big problem is you
can't handle the truth
you don't like hearing it you don't even
know me you know it's just a joke
think about your wife you're in to 1
point 1 million dollars of debt just
forcing her to live in house she's
telling me that I just think over the
last 13 years or what you [ __ ] done
and not to you Deb real standing behind
it I'm tired of hearing that I don't
need it anymore
screw it I really don't care if he
leaves